Hey, welcome back to 40 Days of Holiness. Today is day 30.
Holiness is wholeness. I need to show you the board here so you can hear
the word. It's kind of hard to hear the right word. Wholeness or completeness.
Today, we're in Malachi chapter three. Let's read.
"I will send my messenger who will prepare the way before me,
and then suddenly the Lord you are seeking will come to his
temple. The messenger of the covenant whom you desire
will come,' says the Lord Almighty. 'But who can endure the day of his coming?
Who can stand when he appears? For he will be like a refiner's fire
or a launderer's soap. He will sit as a refiner and
purifier of silver, and he will purify the Levites
and refine them like gold and silver.
And then the Lord will have men who bring offerings in
righteousness."
They will be acceptable. Wholeness is wholeness.
To be whole or healed physically is to be well.
When you're ill, you're not whole.
There's not full, whole physical health.
Recently, my family and I got COVID, and we weren't whole. I ached.
My wife lost her sense of taste and smell.
There was something beyond us that was causing us not to
be fully whole and well.
There is a healed wholeness to holiness,
to being holy. To be spiritually holy and
pursuing holiness is to be whole and on a journey
into full wholeness.
The opposite of whole is mixed. God is holy
because He is whole. He is not mixed with anything else.
He is other. He's not mixed with anything impure.
The old theologians used to talk about without alloy in
the 1700s. That alloy was mixture.
So how does this touch your life? Well, there's no place in this
life of holiness for walling off part of you and saying,
"Holiness doesn't touch this."
You see, God wants to heal and make whole
every part of you.
Your emotions, your reactions, your words.
He wants to heal the hurts of the past.
He wants to deal with your insecurities.
He wants to make you courageous instead of fearful and
insecure. He wants to heal your mind, your
thinking, and reprogram all the parts of you.
Someone watching this is a product of pain.
Other people's sins have marked you, and you feel as though you are
not whole, you are not well, you are mixed, you are forever
damaged, forever scarred, forever marked.
And I'm here to tell you that God's holiness is coming to you to
make all the parts of you whole and well
and unmixed.
Now, He may even use suffering and pain to do this.
The purifier of silver that Malachi talked about would melt the
silver down and skim off the impurities until he could see his
reflection perfectly in the melted silver.
And the purifying work of God is refining.
He may even use trials and pain and counseling and grief and
tears.
The old songwriter said, "The flame shall not hurt
thee. I only design thy dross to
consume and thy gold to refine." And when
that work is done, God says we can offer a sacrifice in
righteousness, a sacrifice that measures up, one that is
whole and not mixed.
That's what you'll offer to God as one made holy, a
whole one made holy.
I felt strongly when I was preparing for this one that someone would be abused who
was watching this. There would be someone watching this who was mistreated,
sinned against, cheated on.
Someone who through harsh words has been abused and
made to feel less worthy and more broken and more
ashamed.
And I felt strongly that the Lord wanted me to come to you and say that
He is healing
that part of you,
and He's making it beautiful again,
and that He's making it whole
so that even the broken parts
that have made you feel ashamed, that you feel like you have to wall off that part
of you and say, "Holiness doesn't touch that."
But instead,
you need to throw open some long-closed doors
and let the healing holiness of God come in,
and let the Spirit's wholeness-creating presence come into that
part of your life to see things
nobody else can see and to touch things that you've always felt no one
else could touch.
I felt strongly that I was supposed to say this to you today because I believe this
is for you. It might not be for anybody else.
It's for you.
You know who I am. You know who I'm talking to right now.
Don't keep those doors closed.
Holiness isn't just something that's for
all these other people. No, holiness is for you.
And God wants to reach down and grab hold of some parts of you and throw
open some things and say, "Let's clean out some of this old bitterness and
this old anger and this old shame and this old hurt.
Let's clean it up, and let's put it back together, and let's make it whole
and healed and beautiful one more time."
We'll see you tomorrow.